il ya eu le chien au 1008 je voulais
présenter ya pas longtemps il y a eu le
1008 trop je voulais présenter il ya
encore moins longtemps
voici maintenant le 1008 light alors le
mieux 8 light me whitling un peu le dur
à prononcer il s'est beaucoup la couleur
de la boîte
je trouve ça hyper ferait presque
printanier ces dommages là on va arriver
doucement sur l'hiver allez savoir mais
je trouve quand même vraiment très très
très sympa et le smartphone des couleurs
le smartphone il est là il est beau il
est chaud il est dans ma poche
ça fait quelques jours que je
l'utilisent que je m'en occupe
j'ai plein de choses avec il a des
points très positifs comme ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur le 1000 8,8 pro mais il
n'est pas du tout cheap pour voir qu'on
est sur un smartphone entrée milieu de
gamme
on n'est pas du tout sur un produit
cheap il ya de très belles finitions
il a vraiment plein de points clippers
hyper intéressant et je pense que ce
produit pour intéresser beaucoup de
monde dans ce que je vous propose tout
de suite maintenant là on va le regarder
de plus près on va détailler un peu tout
ça et je vais vous donnez vos retours
dire ce que j'aime ce que j'aime pas
quoi comment combien là que ça tout ça
tout ça et puis elle un trait ça sera à
vous donner votre tour vous pouvez dès
maintenant commencer directement en bas
en commentaire parce que vous connaissez
2008 light est ce qu'il vous intéresse
est ce que vous l'avez acheté est ce que
vous pourriez acheter
est-ce que vous avez 2008 7,8 pro
comment allez vous comment vos parents
la famille qu'est ce que vous achetez
prendre mais voilà on en parle on y va
maintenant
[Musique]
est ce que cette boîte est pas tout
simplement magnifique j'adore vraiment
ce dégradé de couleurs ce qui a vraiment
une bonne idée là dessus de la partie au
vibrant prix l'emballage est pas non
plus hyper révolutionnaire c'est ce
qu'on connaît déjà
hop je vais vous montrer s'il veut bien
venir un petit peu on a à l'intérieur
ici vous avez une petite coque à
l'intérieur ça c'est cool
vous n'avez pas de prise directe donc là
vous avez une prise jack avec une prise
usb type c vous avez de couvrir votre
tiroir de karting vous avez une petite
coque vous avez de la doc c'est
magnifique c'est beau tout va bien vous
avez un blog charge qui est pas là mais
que j'ai je vous rassure il se recharge
je ne vous le dira en usb type c c'est
cool c'est beau la boîte est sympathique
mais ce qui est vraiment sympathique
c'est le smartphone parce que le
smartphone
il est cool et il est super sympa alors
vous avez une toute petite encoche fin
2018 encoches oblige je trouve pas
problématique c'est encore ça va vous
avez un montant qui est un peu grand
mais de notre côté on est sur un
smartphone a quasiment 270 euros donc ça
va c'est quasiment du bord à bord le
design je trouve très très très efficace
le capteur d'empreintes digitales et
idéalement placé vous prenez en main
vous arrivez directement dessus c'est
très réactif sa déverrouille tout de
suite c'est cool ça marche bien voyez
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
vraiment pratique et surtout vous
n'allez pas du tout flirter avec
l'appareil photo ici double module photo
plus le petit flash led le dos en verre
est très sympa fait son effet à des
petits des petits et fait des petits un
petit peu de relief sais pas si ça se
voit bien comme ça mais c'est vraiment
très sympa bon petit le gaucher aux
mille c'est beau c'est classe sur la
tranche droite bouton pour l'allumer
bouton de volume en dessous vous avez un
haut parleur mono qui situent juste là
usb type c'est ça c'est beau c'est chaud
c'est la déco sur le côté vous avez si
votre tiroir de carte sim sans lequel
vous pouvez mettre soit deux cartes sim
soit une carte sim et une carte micro sd
sur le dessus vous n'avez absolument
rien autant dire que moi je trouve qu'en
termes de prise en main il est très
facile à prendre en main alors j'ai pas
des mêmes bush ont renvoyé il pèse 169 g
on pourrait lui reprocher actuellement
qui sont un petit peu épais sur la
tranche bon voilà c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment du gros bon groupe
points de détails parce que comme ça il
est très sympa alors les stands aux
couleurs
soit en noir avec ses petits reflet soit
en couleur bleu avec cette finition
dégradée dans tous les cas alors la
promesse de ce smartphone c'est quoi
c'est d'abord un excellent rapport
qualité-prix 269 euros vers une 90
centimes pour elle sur une version 4
gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage c'est
vraiment un excellent rapport qualité
prix
vous avez aussi une version aussi giga
de ram 128 go de stockage
si vous avez un peu plus d'exigences ça
coûte 309 euros 90 centimes
il est franchement pas cher très très
bien placé et pour ce qu'il à
l'intérieur c'est super cool parce que
vous avez un écran de 6,26 pouce pour
avec une petite encoche c'est une dalle
ipes c'est du lcd format 19 neuvième
résolution de 1280 par 1080 pixels c'est
du fmi dit plus à 403 pixels par pouce
il fonctionne super bien la luminosité
est ok alors si vous le mettez dehors en
plein soleil vous avez toujours à vous
en sortir mais c'est pas non plus
l'écran le plus lumineux
néanmoins pour du multimédia pour
regarder des vidéos il marche très très
très bien
vous avez une très très belle expérience
dessus c'est hyper hyper agréable pour
l'aspect vidéo multimédia ça marche bien
alors haut parleur mono qui se situe
juste là vous mettez votre main comme ça
ça fait un peu plus de résonance à nous
en dire un peu plus de son il ya de la
puissance franchement ça va franchement
là dessus on n'a absolument rien à leur
reprocher en terme de performances on a
un stade ragone 660 pour moi le cendre
agon 660 ça marche
franchement très très très très bien
côté gpu c'est une adreno 512 c'est pas
un smartphone sur lequel on va aller
chercher les performances les plus
dingues mais par contre pour jouer à des
jeux un peu standard même un pib j'ai ça
marche en version graphique moyenne ça
fonctionne très bien
il peut y avoir quelques lags à droite à
gauche mais ça pose absolument aucun
problème vous avez donc deux versions
comme je le disais soit 4 gigas de ram
soit 6 giga de ram bon 4 gigas de ram
déjà ça ira très bien vous allez
chercher un peu plus de fluidité avec le
6 juillet drame
mais bon sur un smartphone à ce prix là
je suis pas sûr toutefois pas vraiment
hyper hyper hyper pertinents franchement
quand on joue à des jeux vidéo qui
passera de micro ça va ça tartine c'est
vraiment parfait
de ce point de vue là
en termes de performances nation pas
avoir un score complètement fou fou 143
1200 sur en tout c'est franchement
suffisant pour ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce smartphone on va pas chercher là
dessus la puissance comme sur un mille
huit pros comme sur un mille 8 mai pour
jouer à des jeux pour des appuis
classique au courant ça va très très
bien et l'autonomie qu'est ce que dit
l'autonomie vous avez une batterie de
trois mille trois cent cinquante
millions terreur de la recharge en usb
type c'est pour moi c'est pas de la
recharge rapide il faut un certain temps
quand même pour faire le plein néanmoins
vous garder absolument une bonne journée
complète en termes d' usage
alors on va pas faire sauvage bien
évidemment si vous passez votre journée
entière dessus a joué à payer g il ya un
moment ça va coincer ça n'a pas marché
mais toujours un petit peu délicat mais
pour un usage standard à l'eau je prends
un sms chat et email
je vais jouer un petit peu je regarde
des vidéos je me fais plaisir une
journée vous les avez goûté sans aucun
problème jusqu'au lendemain matin mais
il ya un moment vous êtes un petit peu
un court mais il faut donc partir sur
l'idée que ceux 1008 light une journée
il les tient
et ça c'est cool au niveau de l'eau est
ce vous tournez sur un android 8.1 avec
la surcouche me why 9.6 c'est cool ça
marche bien après il ya les plus il ya
des moins ça dépend du goût de chacun
c'est bien ça pourrait être encore mieux
ça fonctionne maintenant la question qui
se pose c'est la partie photo vidéo
autant le 1008 emile vitraux sont
franchement bon en photo mais également
en vidéo
qu'en est il de ceux 1008 light d'un
point de vue spec pour commencer vous
avez ici un double module photo 12 + 5
mégapixels le 12 ouvrant à f 1.9 avec
l'autofocus du à pixels tandis que 5
mégapixels ouvre à f 2.0 et sera là pour
venir renforcer les faits évoqués et va
travailler aussi de concert avec la
partie logicielle pour avoir un flou
d'arrière-plan vraiment optimisé vous
avez 6 à l'avant une caméra frontale de
24 mégapixels à l'arrière vous pouvez
filmer jusqu en 4k à 30 images par
seconde
après deux points de vue logiciel c'est
un petit peu standard vidéo vidéos
courtes photo portrait carré panorama
manuel et vous avez même du slow motion
vous pouvez filmer jusqu'à 120 images
par seconde en full hd trouve celui là
est vraiment excellente
la touche et surtout sonnée beaucoup de
lumière tout de suite si vous avez moins
de lumière le rendu va être moins précis
il va être moins bon l'image mais
beaucoup moins net sous de suite fayard
plus de bruit ça va pas être terrible
terrible
très clairement on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée et milieu de gamme j'irais
plutôt milieu de gamme et à l'entrée du
milieu diable plutôt qu'un smartphone
milieu de gamme qui tire un peu sur le
haut de gamme
néanmoins il a vraiment de très très
très belle prestation au niveau de la
photo
les couleurs sont très bien rendus les
contrastes sont ok c'est pas
complètement sursaturé l'autofocus
dualpix elle marche extrêmement bien là
maintenant je sens la caméra arrière
mais j'ai maintenant passer à l'autre
côté sur la caméra selphy nous voilà
l'avant sur la caméra de cette fille
alors je me regarde en même temps être
moniteur de ce que je vois tout à
l'écran ça a l'air plutôt cool
c'est vrai que xiaomi à une vraie belle
maîtrise au niveau de la photo et de la
vidéo ils vont être bien meilleure au
niveau de la photo que la vidéo
néanmoins le rendu est correct et puis
une fois de plus un smartphone à 269
points 90 il fait franchement bien la
faire et si vous voulez un smartphone
qui soit vraiment de très bonne facture
un tarif pas complètement dingue qui
soit vraiment équilibré en termes de
performances en termes de photos en
terme d'expérience en règle générale ce
1008 light et franchement une super
bonne alternative
le mode portrait fonctionne vraiment
bien le détourage est ok là sur cette
photo il a un petit peu de mal là ici
voyez entre les doigts il n'a pas réussi
à me rétablir le flou bon c'est pas
grave de notre côté le détourage est
assez ok je trouve que ça marche bien au
niveau du visage ça va regarder au
niveau des cheveux mois que les cheveux
gris c'est toujours un petit peu
compliqué pourtant c'est franchement
n'être franchement précis là je me suis
rapproché et il a réussi vraiment à me
détour et le contour là c'était au
milieu là il n'ya pas le flou entre les
doigts mais bon c'est pas hyper hyper
gênant là il a un petit peu de mal en
bas d'un côté on est sur un snapdragon
660 n'a pas la performance d'un dragon
845 mais je trouve que dans l'absolu ça
fonctionne
franchement franchement bien à tilda
fond vous avez
du bluetooth 5.0 dessus alors qu'elle
est la promesse 2008 like parce que
c'est vraiment ce qui est le plus
important
la promesse de semer du maïs est d'avoir
un excellent rapport qualité prix à 270
euros
et franchement pour moi là dessus la
promesse est tenue il est vraiment
équilibré et que ce soit en terme de
performances le cendre agon 660 couplé à
4 g voir si giga de ram si vous voulez
être un petit peu plus gourmand
gourmande c'est complètement possible
pour jouer à des jeux ça va très très
bien
point de vue expériences multimédias sur
de la vidéo ça fonctionne parfaitement
bien
il est réactif l'écran est de bonne
qualité c'est du lcd
ça marche bien pour visionner des vidéos
c'est cool il ya suffisamment de
puissance au niveau du haut parleur mono
vous avez de la recharge en usb tilt
c'est cool
l'autonomie est vraiment bonne les
photos sont excellentes dès lors vous
avez de la lumière faible luminosité
c'est un petit peu moins ça de la côte
on peut pas tout avoir si vous voulez
des photos très bonne en faible
luminosité
il va falloir monter en gamme allez sur
1008 et pourquoi pas 100 mille huit pros
je trouve vraiment cool moi ce
smartphone sauf que vraiment chez lui à
très très très très très très très très
bien bossé là dessus
dites moi ce que vous en pensez à est ce
que ça vous intéresse les produits de
chimie schumi est là depuis le mois de
mai c'est pas très longtemps avant il
fallait les avoir en import export que
la marque en quelques mois a vraiment
mis le paquet c'est vraiment bien fait
connaître continue d'innover avec de
plus en plus présent parce que de toute
façon il faut pour occuper le terrain ça
marche qui est hyper concurrentiel le
smartphone et xiaomi franchement tire
vraiment son épingle du jeu et à une
gamme qui est extrêmement complète entre
l'entrée de gamme et le haut de gamme
dites moi ce que vous en pensez vous et
puis surtout restez connectés parce que
vous allez voir dans les prochaines choi
va voir plein d'excellents modèles le
mx3 que j'ai pu tester assez rapidement
tu vas prendre en main le test aura lieu
l'année prochaine on va reparler de
shinobi parce que j'aime beaucoup cette
marque et je trouve qu'elle a qu'a fait
des promesses qu'elle tient et qu'elle a
des produits qui sont vraiment hyper
hyper hyper cool hyper chouette a vous
de me dire maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire je vous
invite à bien évidemment aller consulter
ma playlist sur les smartphones comme ça
vous verrez il ya plein de produits de
chimie plein d'autres marques qui sont
franchement chouette
et voilà vous souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup de joie on se met des
gros bisous et on se fait la bise
aujourd'hui on se salue allez je te dis
à très bientôt
merci beaucoup prends soin de toi ciao